la Cumbre de la naturaleza de las
Naciones Unidas cerró este lunes con un
acuerdo histórico en Canadá lograron un
compromiso tan relevante como el acuerdo
de París allí sobresale el denominado 30
por 30 el objetivo de proteger el 30% de
la tierra y de las áreas costeras y
marinas al 2030 un buen acuerdo para
todo lo que son las planificaciones
espacial aunque también es cierto que es
insuficiente porque de hecho la ciencia
está pidiendo un 50% de protección del
planeta y no un 30% como se se acordó
también sobresale la conservación de las
tierras indígenas sectores que protegen
cerca del 80% de las especies de plantas
y animales que quedan en la tierra uno
de los puntos de mayor conflicto estuvo
en la financiación los países más
desarrollados aportarán 200.000 millones
por año mientras que las naciones en
desarrollo pretendían mayor cantidad y
la creación de un fondo algo que no
sucedió Primero estamos las áreas esto
significa proteger más áreas significa
obviamente poner más dinero según los
estudios que nosotros hemos este
analizado se necesita un trillón de
dólares cada año la financiación generó
la disconformidad de la República
democrática de Congo el segundo país con
mayor cantidad de bosques tropicales del
mundo pero las autoridades chinas no
contemplaron el planteo congolenio como
formal y avanzaron con el acuerdo el
cual tan valió y según representantes
africanos fue aprobado por la fuerza
esta resolución sustituye a los firmados
en Haití en 2010 que nunca se cumplieron
seguros de haichi fueron acuerdos muy
ambiciosos que no se cumplieron debido a
que no habían mecanismos de
implementación claros los cuales nadie
se hacía responsable porque no había
ninguna manera de ponerlos en la mesa la
cumbre en Montreal apunta a cumplir una
necesidad global evitar una mayor
pérdida de poblaciones de biodiversidad
ya devastadas